triangle ABC contains an inscribed  rectangle of Dimensions five by one and  another rectangle of dimensions three by  one what is the height of the triangle  upon the base BC  here's how we can work it out let's  label this distance as H now this  triangle has a height of h and a base of  3 and that will be similar to this  triangle here now we know its base is  equal to 5 and let's label this length  and that will be equal to one so this  triangle has a base of 5 and a height of  h plus one  therefore H upon 3 is equal to h plus 1  upon 5. cross multiplying gives 5H is  equal to 3 multiplied by the quantity h  plus one this means five H is equal to  three h plus three so two H is equal to  3 and H is equal to 1.5  now substituting in we just label one  more height and that will be equal to  one so the total height is going to be  1.5 plus one plus one which equals 3.5